>> All right, so we've defined our terms, we,
we know, what it takes to do, at least
supervised learning. So now I want to do a specific
algorithm and a specific representation, that allows us to solve
the problem of going from instances to, actual concepts.
So what we're going to talk about next are decision trees.
And I think the best way to introduce decision
trees is through an example. So, here's the very simple
example I want you to think about for a
while. You're on a date with someone. And you come
to a restaurant. And you're going to try to decide
whether to enter the restaurant or not. So, your, input,
your instances are going to be features about the
restaurant. And we'll talk a little bit about what those
features might be. And the output is whether you
should enter or not. Okay, so it's a very simple,
straightforward problem but there are a lot of
details here that we have to figure out.
>> It's a classification problem.
>> It's clearly a classification problem because
the output is yes, we should enter or
no, we should move on to the next restaurant. So in fact, it's not just
a classification problem, it's those binary classification
problems that I said that we'd almost exclusively
be thinking about for the next few minutes.
Okay. So, you understand the problem set up?
>> Yes, though I'm not sure exactly what the pieces of the input are.
>> Right, so thats actually the right next question to ask. We
have to actually be specific now about a representation. Before I was drawing
squiggly little lines and you could imagine what they were, but now since
we're really going to go through an example, we need to be clear about
what is it mean to be standing in front of the restaurant.
So, let's try to figure out how we would represent that, how we
would define that. We're talking about, you're standing in front of a restaurant
or eatery because I can't see the reliably small restaurant. And we're going to
try to figure out whether we're going to go in
or not. But, what do we have to describe our
eatery? What do we have? What are our attributes? What
are the instances actually made of? So, what in, or
another way of putting it is, what are the features
that we need to pay attention to that are going to
help us to determine whether we should yes, enter into
the restaurant. Or no, move on to the next restaurant.
So, any ideas Michael?
>> Sure. I guess there's like the type of restaurant.
>> Okay,
>> Oh, is it tall or short, and is it a good credit risk?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Oh wait, no, no, no wait, I know.
Like the Italian versus French, versus, you know, Vietnamese.
>> So let's call that the type.
So it could be Italian, it could be French, it could
be Thai, it could be American, there are American restaurants, right?
>> Sure.
>> Greek, it can be, Armenian. It can any kind of
restaurant you want to. Okay, good. So that's something that probably
matters because maybe you don't like Italian food or maybe you're
really in the mood for Thai. Sounds perfect. Okay anything else?
>> Sure. How about whether it smells good?
>> You know, I like cleanliness. Let's let's, or
you know what, let's, let's be nice to our eateries and let's say atmosphere.
>> Mm. Right because if there's, you know, no atmosphere,
then it is going to be really hard to breathe.
>> That's exactly right. So is it
fancy? Is it a hole-in-the-wall, which I'm going
to spell HIW. Is it a hole-in-the-wall,
umm, those sorts of things. The, you know?
>> Casual, I guess, is another category.
>> Casual.
And so on, and so forth. You could imagine
lots of things like that, but these things might matter
to you and your date. Okay, so, we know the
type of the restaurant that we have, we know whether
it's fancy, whether it's casual, whether it's a hole
in the wall. Some of the best food I've ever
had are in you know, well-known hole in the walls.
Those sorts of things. Anything else you can think of?
>> Sure, Sometimes, I might use
something like looking inside and seeing whether
there's people in there and whether they look they're having a good time.
>> Right. So that's an important thing. So let's just say
If it's occupied. Now why might that matter in reality? Well
it matters because if it's completely full and you may have to
wait for a very long time, you might not want to
go in. On the other hand. If you're looking at a restaurant
you've never heard of, and there's only two people in it,
and it's Friday at 7 p.m. Maybe that says something about something.
Maybe you want it to be quiet. You know, those sorts
of things might matter. Okay, so, we've got type, we've got atmosphere,
we've got occupied. Anything else you can think of?
>> And I have been out of the dating market for a while, but I guess
it could imagine, I could imagine how hard
I am trying to work to impress my date.
>> perfect. So do you have a hot date or not? Or, this is
someone who you really, really, really want to impress and so, maybe it matters
then, it's even more important whether it's a fancy restaurant or a hole in
the wall, or whether it's French or
whether it's an American restaurant. That make sense?
I think that makes sense. Notice, by the way, that the
first two sets that we have have multiple possible categories here.
So it could be Italian, French, Thai, American, so on and
so forth. Atmosphere is something that can have many, many possible
values, but the last two things that we talked about were
all binary. Either it's occupied or it's not. Yes or no
or, you have a hot date or you don't. And I
think we could go on like this for a long time but,
let's try to move on to maybe a couple of other features
and then try to actually figure out how we may actually solve this.